what is there to gain from smashing all
these particles together and breaking
them apart and
dissecting them and looking them what
how do you advance
from that okay now that's a very good
question
um what drives first of all and i think
at the point what drive scientists is a
better
understanding of how the world works so
i get that question asked a few times
what's the value particularly on my
youtube videos
where people go what a waste of money
right um let me
let me draw out a few examples in
history
that actually ask the same question but
it'll drive the point i'm trying to make
home
michael faraday i'm not sure if you're
familiar with the scientist the 19th
century
right um was working with electricity he
discovered that electricity and
magnetism
how they have an intricate connection
and
and you know electricity was very new at
that time
um now this quote that i'm about to use
is apocryphal they're not sure
whether he actually he said it but
someone basically said look uh
you know what use is this electricity
and his comment is well
i don't know but i'm sure the government
will one day will find a way to tax it
and you know the insight is is that oh
this electricity
is there any use for it but you know 50
years 100 years down the track
we know how useful it is um in
the 1880s heinrich hertz was examining
the concept of these waves that
a guy by the by the name of james clerk
maxwell discovered i did a video on this
and he discovered these waves these
electromagnetic waves
and the name that was given to them was
radio waves
and it was a very important experiment
because it
supported and validated what maxwell's
research had done
he himself hurts had said i don't think
there's any practical use for these ways
but they're interesting
you know and again a hundred ten years
later we had marconi sending the first
uh signal from new york to paris
via radio waves you know um and
of course radio waves drives bluetooth
so it drives wi-fi
drives tv drives our telecommunications
you know again had someone said heard
stop
researching it's not worthwhile doing
that because there's no use for society
well you know what would be missing out
now all right
um and then in the 20s and 30s
scientists were interested in
particular types of materials that
behave strangely in that
normally when you heat a substance
its resistance the ability to carry a
current actually drops
but it is the micro faraday discovered
this material called silicon
or determined that silicon actually
increases its
conductivity when it raises its
temperature a little bit
um but understanding of why that
led to what we refer to as often what we
call semiconductor research
again purely it was driven by the fact
of
i want to know more i want to know
what's going on here
in order to what drives this but
from that came the concept of the
transistor
the integrated circuit all our computer
technology is based on that
including solar cells as well which is
which also uses semiconductors
so i guess the question i then i want to
basically
answer your question there are aspects
of certain and particle accelerators at
this stage
you could say look it's not about what
we get out of it it's not a
basically a thing about simply about
you know what we gain out of it as a
society
in terms of a practical use right
it's about understanding nature but i
will add
um there have been many
benefits already that we've benefited
from institutions such as cern
in 1989 uh but a guy by the name of
tim berners-lee developed a way of
communicating information across a
computer network
in order to com in order to support you
know
communication between scientists at cern
he created the world wide web
so you know that came out of him the
idea of um
uh you know um using our phone
and this what we refer to as capacitive
touch
the fact that there's a touch well that
came out of basically cern
they had this panel to this to basically
control this uh
particle accelerator they had way too
many buttons how can we do it in such a
way that we could make one button do
multiple things depending on what you
touch so capacitive touch came out of
that
um we have technologies such as
pet scans i'm not usually familiar with
pet scans
but pt scans is basically using the
concept of particles
to diagnose and in some cases treat
cancers
so using again
the technology we now have machines that
are able to diagnose and treat cancers
uh or pet technology and current
research is
using what we refer to as hadron therapy
there's that word adron again yeah if we
fire
a beam of protons or we can even use
beam of electrons i just read a recent
article about
uh uh and on cern's website actually
of using a beam of electrons we can
actually treat cancers with
far less side effects so in essence to
give you a short story assuming
you know my coffee mug is my human body
here
and i fire a beam of gamma radiation to
treated cancer well i'm going to damage
all the cells along as well as my tumor
and so what they do is to say okay if i
be if i'm a beam
this way and a fire beam this way and if
i beam this way
and all the different places and they
all intersect with the tumor as well i'm
going to kill the tumor
but i still will damage all those cells
around it to a certain degree
right i discovered that if you fire a
beam of hadrons or beam of electrons
they actually behave differently they
actually drop most of their energy where
you want them to
so in other words you can actually has
cause little very little damage
but then do all the damage where the um
tumor is now that technology comes out
of the technology that cern's produced
in order to understand
nature so you know no we won't find
necessarily
a direct use of the fact that our
protons and our neutrons are made up of
quarks
but the technology that has been
developed
to work that out um has had
many and i'm just using a medical
example that have been industrial uh
material
um based technologies robotics and so
forth that have come out of places such
as soon
because you know there's technology
someone said hold on that's really good
to understand that
but you know what let's apply that to
this situation and all of a sudden we
have now
you know utility out of a a discovery of
our of our universe if that makes sense
so is that treatment
that cancer treatment where they shoot
the the
hydrogen atoms or what they are yeah the
protons yep hydrotherapy
yeah when they shoot the protons have
they actually tested that on humans
yeah uh yeah there's actually uh yeah it
is actually a
uh feasible technology error as we speak
however the problem is the cost so um
it's not something that you can say you
know every every corner
um hospital can have it
so there are a number of places in i
think that i can't
quite don't quote me on this but i think
there are two or three senses in europe
that currently
offer hadron therapy um there may be a
few more
it but it's it's an emerging technology
but yes it has been used to successfully
treat cancers
um and so um
yeah i i the issue that's that stops it
growing
is the um it's simply the cost factor
you know in order to reduce that so but
that's that's been true for
a lot of machines so you know i'm not
sure if you've ever had an mri
magnetic residence imaging um in any in
many respects our understanding of
matter through the work from cern and
fermilab and all others that
really is as a
is basically uh the reason why we have
machines such as
mri machines for example um
you know if you want to if you were in
the 70s and wanted mri
the doctor would laugh at you like it
was like you know it's too expensive
you know there's only a few places now
now of course mri machines are
basically found in any any small town um
because
the technology's improved and the cost
of running has improved and so forth
um the same with you know uh ct scans
same same thing you know
ct scans were developed in the 90s and
40s and 50s but didn't really come into
their own and so much in the 70s and 80s
because of costs
being reduced and so forth
i